[موسيقى]
صوره واحده فقط صدرت من هنا في امريكا
وتحولت الى زلزال في مصر فما القصه
[موسيقى]
هل تعرفي
كيلوباترا ببشره سمراء
ملصق دعائي لسلسله وثائقيه ستعرضها منصه
نتفليكس في العاشر من مايو السلسله تروي
سيره اخر ملكات مصر الفرعونيه ومنتجه
العمل ليست الا جيده
الذي دافع عنها خلال حفل الاوسكار في
العام الماضي
صفع حينها مقدم الحفل كروس روك بسبب نكته
سمجه عن شعر جيده لكن كيلوباترا السمراء
ويعلن مفارقه تعيد جيد سميث الى الاضواء
وعنوان هذه المفارقه حركه
هي حركه فكريه تعتقد ان مصر القديمه حكمها
الافارقه ذو البشره السمراء والفراعنه
قدموا من قلب افريقيا ليصبحوا فراعنه مصر
هذه الفكره تغضب المصريين كثيرا فكيف تبدو
الصوره من ارض كيلوباترا صوره كليوباترا
السمراء تحولت ازمه وعرائضه مع عشرات الاف
طواقيع والمطلب واحد اوقفوا عرض السلسله
ولكن هل هناك شيء من العنصريه في هذا
الغضب المصري
[موسيقى]
المعترضون لديهم رساله واضحه ليست هناك
مشكله ان تكون الملكه سمراء المشكله ان
يكون ذلك تزييفا للتاريخ الاثر مرفوضون
عموما هنا في مصر تذكروا كليوباترا مصريه
يونانيه وهي اخر من حكم مصر القديمه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات